there is little more irritating than
running out of loo roll this Factory in
Bridgend is trying to make sure the
country doesn't get caught short by
brexit we / make toilet paper tissues
and kitchen roll for customers across
the UK and Europe and with just ten days
to go until a potential No Deal they're
taking no chances we built up an
additional 1,500 tons worth of finished
goods which is about a month's worth of
additional stock I'll be honest with you
we've been here before so I'm not
counting any chickens and we're still
preparing for a harbor exit and we will
continue to do so to make sure that our
customers are in despite the
parliamentary chaos and the opposition
of a majority to No Deal the man
responsible for preparation says it
remains a serious threat and not just a
ploy to persuade MPs I must I fear
tickly appropriate steps now to prepare
for the increased possibility that the
legal default position will follow and
we will leave on October the 31st
without a deal the clear advice to me
from officials is that we must now
intensify contingency arrangements
tickets for ferries that will carry
emergency medical supplies have gone on
sale the m20 will close overnight this
weekend to prepare for potential customs
delays and Manston airfield in Kent is
being readied to receive almost six
thousand lorries here in Whitehall
hundreds of civil servants are working
on No Deal contingency plans
despite the Prime Minister asking for a
brexit extension they may never be
needed but they will cost the taxpayer
that's a luxury many businesses cannot
afford this is the third time in seven
months that companies have prepared for
brexit but some retailers would prefer
more time to examine the new deal - a
quick fix none of us would buy a house
without having a survey without getting
the surveyors in without checking with
the lawyers without understanding
whether the valuation is right so why
would you do a deal for the ages without
that level of scrutiny and we already
have seen one or two areas where we
think it's a concern
the impact on Northern Irish businesses
has become clearer after the government
admitted goods crossing the Irish Sea to
England Scotland and Wales will require
customs declarations but there will be
no assessment of the economic impact
after the Chancellor ruled it out the
cost of brexit as well as how and when
Britain leaves remains unknown Paul
Kelso sky news